all right so the sole reason I'd yet to
do a top 10 movie list of 2010 is
because I thought to myself if I'd do it
before I watch 127 hours I might be
robbing a well-deserving movie of being
on one of the most prestigious lists and
film and I am glad I waited
[Music]
a hundred and twenty seven hours it's a
lot longer than it sounds so this is the
true story directed by Danny Boyle of a
rock climbers thrill seeker type played
by James Franco who's one of those yeah
I'm invincible nothing can hurt me live
on the edge because tomorrow you might
be dead types which is all good great
and fine until a boulder falls on his
arm pinning him in the B Fe canyons of
Utah and after that no one on earth
knows where he is except him he's a
pretty grim situation now there's
definitely something to be said about a
movie that takes place in one spot with
one person for about an hour and a half
that's tough to pull off and keep people
interested let alone make it intense but
this movie absolutely pulls it off now
James Franco was awesome in this movie
and he's had quite the career too he was
a freak and a geek and then he was the
new goblin sorta then it was on General
Hospital and now he's going for the
Oscar and yeah he'll most definitely get
nominated then again a couple years ago
I would have said the dark night would
have been nominated so I mean what do I
know but what I like about this movies
when situations like this happen when
the situation is so bleak people will do
one of two things one they'll be like
it's done it's over let's just roll over
and die or two they'll do the James
Franco or the dude it's based off of in
fairness I'd say that and they'll just
be like if deaths coming for me I ain't
going without a fight there's going to
be a Throwdown I just like that I like
seeing people like that I just like
seeing people's will to survive you know
it's a really realistic feeling this is
a really realistic movie almost like an
unsettling degree I mean the camerawork
was great everything came together to
really show what he's going through like
by the end of the movie he's just out of
his mind dehydrated he's just tripping
balls probably had a fun time tripping
out in pineapple express but you know it
was good it was like an oscar-worthy
movie without being like in-your-face
artsy whenever a director can make an
oscar-worthy movie without the art scene
is just being all up in your [ __ ] I'm
okay with that in fact it's pretty great
so 127 hours is oscar-worthy and by that
I mean well acted well directed powerful
and thought-provoking
it's a shut up dude I got so thirsty in
this movie I'm not even joking at all
halfway into the movie I was about as
thirsty as Franco I mean when's the last
time you can actually say that when's
the last time you can say I went to a
movie and I was watching it I was so
enthralled by it I was so into it that
it actually physically affected me so
it's either great directing or it's just
a big ploy to get you to buy overpriced
concessions so death no no so if you're
lucky
to live next to one of the I don't know
seven theaters in the country that's
playing it go check it out otherwise I
think it's getting a wider release in
January I think so there it is that is
127 hours so stay tuned for this weekend
to see my top 10 best and top 10 worst
movies of 2010 and if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more than click right here to see more
[Music]